[Music]
can you believe it the day has finally
come we can now change our PlayStation
Network IDs so if you've had your PSN
name since you were a child and after
all those years of shame and ridicule
you finally have the chance to now
remove it
whether it's spam dagger double-oh-seven
lady lover 69 maybe you have an
embarrassing clan tag to get rid of or
potentially you are one of those weird
strange people who put X X before and
after their name as of right now you can
change that there's a few things you
really should know before you change
your ID but if you're 100% certain jump
to this timecode for a quick
demonstration everyone else let's cover
the basics first cost the first time you
change your online ID it will be
completely free of charge absolutely
nothing to pay but should you do it
again it will cost ten dollars in the US
and Canada ten euros in the EU or eight
pound in the UK but if you're a PS Plus
subscriber you can have that cost five
dollars five euros or four pounds at any
point you can do this again change as
often as you'd like but you'll have to
stump up the cache of cost so what
happens to your old PSN ID well it's
it's still yours no one can claim it
it's hidden away at any point you wish
to return to your old tag which is
probably booty shaker by nine or two or
no you can do it completely for free at
any point there's a potential issue
though for longtime gamers due to how
the PSN was built some games do not
support the name change infrastructure
in most cases you'll simply play using
your previous name you know monkey
ticklin 900 but in some cases DLC may
not be accessible some features just
won't work in-game currency can be lost
online features may not be playable I
know that seems a little scary but also
know that any game published after April
the 1st 2018 is completely guaranteed to
support this new feature so if you're
certain you want to change your PSN ID
from flaccid Womble 1992 to something
more appropriate here's how you do it on
your ps4 first go over to settings and
look for account management next account
information then over to profile and
finally online ID at some point here you
will definitely need your login password
so I'll keep it in mind
you
be greeted with all the warnings I've
already told you about but this is your
last chance to back out and keep your
nineties ID forever and ever
now it's a case of trying to find an ID
that still exists and it's harder than
you think once complete you'll have an
additional option of how you want the
update to be seen your original ID is
still there but you can hide it now
there we go
don't underst it I have literally no
idea why I'm now called nada Maru but I
guess I don't have to live with it
anymore at least it's also possible to
change your ID through a web browser
I'll put the details in the comments
below I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
so if your name is das Basha 48 so if
you've been called Bret the Hitman sharp
since 1996 Dreamcast fiddling 96 so if
you're called Mario fart 64 now is this
do this